j'en vois une différence entre la gare
actuelle et le logement c'est à dire que
le dos jean c'était plus romantiques
escalade wright maintenance et c'est dur
c'est rue ce que ça se produise un seul
coup maintenant romantique c'est plutôt
c'est une honte je crois j'ai pas moi
j'avoue je suis romantique avec une
fille en bas je me sens vraiment pas
rétrograde
les dragons n'est pas romantique plaçons
quand tu leur as qu'une les nets tout ce
que lui tu racontes
c'est du baratin heureusement je crois
que ça se perd le coup bon c'est une
gonzesse dans la rue ou alors aller dans
une terrasse de café ce que vous voulez
boire un coup parce que c'est vraiment
d'un seul coup sans connaître la fit
quoi tu veux y aller tu veux la drague
et tu veux te l'emballé ou un truc comme
ça alors moi les filles qui accepte
d'entrer un type qui vient tout ça qui
essayait d'avoir arrivent les beaux yeux
de tous comme ça moi c'est pas
intéressant
comment une fille comme ça
10 heures le soir seuls dans paris les
amis sont partis d'un trench quand même
se marier en dragon
oui un peu oui oui oui comment ça fait
petit bassin puis si tu as we à côté moi
oui bavaro j'allais à une piscine qui
était proche de mon boulot oui là il y
avait une dame que j'avais repéré dans
le point elle était jolie et alors
je lui ai offert de lui apprendre à
nager j'ai piloté un peu naturellement
ces voiliers bons appuis comme julie les
baisers pas vers la colline à savoir est
un site il ya près d'une semaine est ce
que vous aimeriez vous marier avec un
dragueur oh non jaloux j'ai pas
tellement ça c'est bonjour je drague moi
oui vous inviter une jeune fille comment
ça se passe s'il arrive à ne fait à rire
[Musique]
oui c'est ça si les droits mal à 20h de
l'argent pour draguer
oubliez ça marche autre morceau la belle
voiture aussi la belle moto y a pas de
réciprocité ben n'en parlons pas bien il
va me rendre de déclarer non mais on
doit respecter absolument la liberté
d'autrui le bassiste ex était là moi
j'ai pas besoin de minutes les beaux
draps voici je voudrais quelqu'un c'est
tous pour le physique et je m'en fous de
ce qu'il a dans la tête vous me plaisait
beaucoup
cessez vos yeux bleus je sais pas si tu
dis qu'une fille qui suivra garuet pas
très intéressante et du tout bon
peut-être qu elle s 10 en elle-même mon
style siens à bidon mais en tout cas
d'ira suis fier quand même
elle est flatté quand même parce que je
dis vous mangez plus à ce type au fond
de moi même si tu veu diret pas dire à
celui qui à côté de ma roue et 7 cas
écoutez moi moi quand tu vas dans un
magasin quand tu vois de marchandises
pourquoi tu l'achètes bon parce qu'elle
est bien agencé ou ce que le produit est
beau c 58
quand tu vois une gonzesse qui est une
fibre par les biens cassis dans un bar
quand tu vas pour l'aborder c'est pas
pour se caler pour ce qu'elle pense
parce que tu la connais pas c'est pour
comment allait son physique si elle a un
physique avantageux si elle plaît alors
tu prends la gonzesse zafy pour une
marchandise n'est absolument pas
d'accord avec toi moi je suis amoureux
de vous
mais je les comprend peut-être les
maquis qui essayent de draguer comme ça
c'est peut-être que par derrière ils ont
rien d'autre à donner ou à montrer à
leur seule possibilité c'est de draguer
comme sa terrasse d'un café ou dans la
rue une fille dragueuse c'est quand même
une fille qui essaye de se libérer de
quelque chose parce que c'est toujours
le mec qui doit drague est aussi la
fille a drag c'est quand même un acte de
courage you like musique
non parce que nico zahia
des billets de concert méfiez-vous
c'est un truand mademoiselle vous êtes
la femme de ma vie
si vous êtes à femme de ma vie je vous
assure je vous assure je vous ai vu de
loin là c'est merveilleux oui vous vous
les voulez je vous en prie après vous
êtes sûr c'est raté c'est pas possible
ça peut être que mois et coûté 1 3 l à
travailler mais la pluie prend le puits
draguer draguer ramé ramé boîte de nuit
boîte à fric boîtes de conserves de foie
question je pense que tu fasses je suis
déjà venu ici on drague également y en a
qui viennent pour ça y'a l'ado qui
viennent pour autre chose est cependant
certaine mandé val où il ya certainement
le plus de mariages
peut-être dans tout paris
je sais qu'ils attaquent avec
ce qui vous est arrivé une mésaventure
une forme à l'arrivée 2 oui j'ai failli
y penser aussi du 7e étage
à bize part à ces ragots qui voulait
profiter de moi alors que moi c'est
peut-être pour la danse étaient propres
et saines en finit pas qu'est ce que je
regrette d'avoir dit oui à ce type en
plus il s'est aspergé d'eau toilettes
mobiles comme un commandant et plus
l'autre fois avec une camarade qui est
un petit peu voilà on a failli passer
retraités blanche
il a dit que les basiques on voit bien
ce qui drague et ceux qui drague pas
alors c'est à vous de vous évincé mais
quelquefois c'est difficile parce que
maintenant les jeunes sont plus
virulents vis-à-vis dosage pour ça que
je peux plus me permettre d'y aller
d'abord sur une tête banquette et un
supplément si vous traîne à 3
malheureusement et du passé un mauvais
quart d'heure
[Musique]